let's begin with the obvious today was
an important day for the bond market
because we got a Fed statement any
surprises for you in the fed statement
not much you know they spoke to
transitory transit orally low inflation
same thing in terms of growth we had a
GDP number today at out of a hideous GV
appoint two percent actually a real
final sales which scratches out
inventories was a minus point five
percent so dumb really hideous and do
with that negative number but i don't
think the statement suggested much
difference in terms of their attitude
going forward they think inflation's
going higher to hopefully to two percent
they think real GDP is in a two to three
percent zone and so they're going to sit
and wait until they get there so what
conclusions then you draw about the
timing of a rate increase right now well
i think it's a it's often june that some
would say if we get a strong employment
report awake from now that perhaps it's
back on but i think it's off and i think
perhaps they'd simply want to get off
the dime they want to prove that they're
not healthy but that they can get out of
bed and stand on their own two legs and
that means you know a 25 basis point
increase perhaps in September or
December but from that point forward and
that's the key of you know how quickly
will they move back to what you know we
know as a new neutral policy rate and
what would that be well to my way of
thinking that it would be two percent
nominal tan 0% a real now the old
standard the John Taylor Taylor rule
standard was basically a four percent
nominal rate and a two percent real rate
just you know some of the fed members a
lot of the dots those blue dots you know
basically suggests that the three and
three quarters to four percent nominal
is still the number but I hesitate so as
far as June is concerned you don't read
anything into the FOMC removing that
sentence from the previous two
statements about an increase in the feds
funds target being unlikely at the next
meeting I don't think so they were
moving in that direction I'm in the head
of transition four or five times in
terms of the language and I think they
want the language out of there in turn
of time dependency they want to be data
dependent and and the data to a
considerable extent revolves around
employment and labor and inflation do
you think it's important for Jenny Ellen
and her colleagues to be able to prove
that in your words they can get out of
bed and stand on their own two feet I
think so and I think it's important from
the standpoint of the health of a
capitalistic economy which is something
that hasn't been discussed a lot in
terms of fed meetings but I think low
interest rates can have negatives as
well as Potter's positives I mean the
Fed is always sense that the lower the
rate the better in terms of stimulating
the economy capital market stocks you
know to flow down in terms of wealth etc
etc but at some point when rates are so
low you know you keep alive zombie
corporations because they can borrow so
cheaply you basically you know promote a
situation which business models pension
funds insurance companies banks you know
can't earn what they're supposed to earn
and so at some point capitalism at the
margin not totally but at the margin
begins to break down and so I think it
is important that they move back up to a
least a semblance of a healthy fed funds
rate